we have entered a season of love
and you can soak it all in at the
bellagio conservatory
rocky is there live to get the story
behind their newest display hey rocky
hey you guys yeah you said season of
love it sounds like valentine's day
right but
it is not it is not i'm here with ed
libby he is the designer of this
beautiful bellagio conservatory that we
love to visit
tell us the story behind this particular
season of love great to see
welcome rocky so this is the season of
love is our love here of nature our love
of commitment
our love of tradition family travel we
worked at the feng shui master and kind
of developed this beautiful love story
our exhibit and and valentine's day in
the west coincide with each other and
we're telling beautiful love stories
through
our floral art here and this is the
theme is lunar new year right
it's it is lunar new year and the the
strength and endurance of the ox is what
we're relying on to get us through
this lovely story together and get us
into a new part of hopefully a better
season
to come um so we're telling these like
great these great fables
through our floral art in in the
conservatory in our gardens
and what i love about this display i
think this might be my new fave actually
honestly i'm telling you because it's
minimal and it's just
elegant yeah it is we took a much
different approach
to to the exhibit this time we really
are telling the story
in a very um in in a way that it's not
so obvious this time
but the asian clients that have come
through have told this story to
so many of us so many times the the the
story of the jade emperor's daughter
this bridge of magpies that were made
the ox herd
the benson for the lovers it's a it's a
very traditional story
that's told in a very interpretive kind
of way this time which is a little bit
different than what we've been doing in
the past
that's why i love coming here to visit
you because we can come and see this but
we don't always get to
understand the meaning behind it but now
i want to move over here to the
conservator of the conservatory which
you called it
leslie tell us why people should come
down and visit just break it down
we have our lunar new year display up
for 10 weeks so lots of opportunity
the actual lunar new year gala falls on
february 12th
and just two days before valentine's day
so
this place is so very romantic at night
the moon is eliminated it's just a
lovely place to come
day or night we have a during those 10
weeks
we will go through over 62 000
live plants or cut flowers so we have
the chinese children who
are costumed with cut carnations cut
chrysanthemums leslie i hate to
interrupt you because i'm
i'm in a trance with the music and what
you're telling me but coming up in the
floor we're going to hear more of that
so you guys stay tuned i'll send it back
to you guys in studio
thank you rocky yeah we cannot wait to
hear more about it we'll check back in
with you in the 4pm newscast
all right